today on the Matt Walsh show some states
are coming out of lock downs while other
states are extending the lock downs for
no medically or scientifically
justifiable reason what's one thing that
the extension states seem to mostly have
in common well they're run by Democrats
what does that tell us we'll talk about
that also five headlines including
NASA's plan to intentionally create a
meteor shower by slamming something into
an asteroid they're gonna be doing this
soon should we be concerned about that
also a CNN is bringing Greta Thune Berg
on to their expert coronavirus panel
which is gonna air tonight issue really
an expert in anything well my answer to
that may actually surprise you and in
our daily cancellation I will finally be
canceling the hero-worship of nurses I
suspect this segment will get me into a
little bit of trouble we'll get to that
all coming up but first I want to tell
you about our friends the Benham
brothers you know one thing we're gonna
also talk about the news segment is the
unemployment rate which continues to go
up dramatically every single week the
effect that obviously these shutdowns
have had on small businesses has been
has been catastrophic which is why it's
never been more important if you're a
business owner to manage your business
your workforce and your work flow really
well systems are always important
they're crucial right now the Benham
brothers are great at this these guys
have over a dozen businesses including a
real estate empire that spans thirty
five states just a few weeks ago the
Benton brothers launched a new podcast
called expert ownership and in their new
podcast the benin brothers interview
leaders from all walks of life to help
you navigate your business during these
crucial times these challenging times
you'll hear from leaders like Senator
Ted Cruz L Robertson from duck dynasty
many more so you can go check out their
new podcast I would definitely recommend
it I've listened to it myself it's great
very informative expert ownership is the
podcast and be sure to subscribe on
Apple podcasts or wherever you listen
we'll drop a link to their podcast in
our show description again that's expert
ownership go check it out right now all
right
so let's take a look around the state of
Michigan under Empress whitmer a
Democrat extended its stay at home order
at least until the end of May at least
Pennsylvania under emperor Wolf's
Democrat extended its state
order into June California under emperor
Newsom a Democrat has a state-owned home
order in place indefinitely until they
get to a point where they go two weeks
without anyone dying of coronavirus
which is another way of saying their
stay at home order is in place forever
it would seem Wisconsin under Emperor
Tony Evers a Democrat tried to extend
its stay at home owner but the state
Supreme Court just struck it down which
is great thank God by the way Wisconsin
has had four hundred and eighteen
coronavirus deaths total that's it this
whole time in three months four hundred
eighteen and the governor wanted to keep
the state home order in place now you
can't help but notice something about
these states and the rest of the states
that are extending their lock downs
rather than ending them you can't help
but notice that mostly these are states
run by Democrats now I've never been a
conspiracy theorist on this whole thing
now the idea that these lockdowns
were originally conceived purely as a
way to wreck the economy in order to
destroy trumps reelection chances you
know I didn't I didn't buy that and I
still don't now for one thing Republican
governors were doing it too
and for another Trump himself has been
on board with it so now he's vacillated
the whole time and been quite indecisive
but if it was nothing but a plot against
him and he was himself a part of it and
cheering it on in approving of it then
that would make him either politically
suicidal or the dumbest dupe in the
history of dumb dupes but I don't think
that's the case I think originally there
was fear panic incompetence a total lack
of clarity a total lack of any kind of
plan and in the midst of all that these
little would-be dictators these petty
tyrants found an opportunity to exert
the kind of control that they've always
wanted to exert it's all reason they got
into politics we have to remember the
reason most people get into politics is
because they want to control people they
want to be in charge they're narcissists
that the vast majority of people I mean
there's no that's
that's the only motivation you could
have aside from a deep and sincere
desire to serve people okay and and
maybe in the history of politics there
have been like three people who actually
got into it for that reason everybody
else is because they're narcissists they
want to control people so um they like
the power you know they as the lockdowns
continue they discovered they get a lot
of power they liked controlling every
aspect of everybody's lives they liked
doing as all the governors have done the
their you know daily press conferences
and having everybody watch and they
liked having their citizens who really
now felt like their citizens not
citizens of the state or the country but
citizens their citizens they liked
having them hang on every word you know
their every decree and that I believe
explains how the lockdown started and
why it continued but now as the curve
has been flattened and as many states in
the country most states in fact never
had a coronavirus emergency and in fact
had been plagued with sort of the
opposite with empty hospitals and laid
off hospital staffs this whole time not
to mention millions of unemployed and
laid off citizens in other sectors of
the economy now as we inch closer to the
election we're gonna see politics play a
much bigger role than it did perhaps at
the beginning whereas it was a bunch of
governors having ego trips at the
beginning rubble Republican and Democrat
now the political calculations really
starts to take hold we are in a
precarious and volatile situation as a
country right now truly unlike anything
in recent history at least coming out or
continuing in these lockdowns with a
presidential election only months away
and that's an election that was already
going to be itself extremely volatile
even more than normal just based on the
sheer hatred that Trump's have enemies
have for him and so of course you know
Democrats are gonna say to themselves
well if we open up
everything turns out okay and the
economy starts to climb back and in
everything and recover Trump is gonna
get credit for that from their
perspective going into an election after
having survived a pandemic on the
upswing in recovery optimism hope relief
all of that that's not good politically
it's just not that's not the mood that's
not the attitude you want if you're
challenging the incumbent you want fear
despair anger hopelessness and there is
just no way at that's at this point
there's just no way that that isn't part
of the calculation for these Democrats I
mean just look at what's happening in
Los Angeles under their Democrat mayor
lockdown extended three months the mayor
announced yesterday that all residents
in the city have to wear a mask
whenever they leave their homes for any
reason no matter where they're going
even even if they're gonna be outside
the whole time walking around the block
checking on mailbox you need a you need
a mask he quote reopened the beaches but
let's take a look at what his reopening
of the beaches and tales and I know I
should be used to this craziness by now
but this is just let's take a look I'll
show you this and in fact before we do
that I want to tell you about our
sponsors policy genius life is very
unpredictable all the time especially
now I think we've all discovered that
and as an insurance marketplace policy
Gina's take talks a lot about how
unpredictable the future is and that's
why insurance exists in the first place
right now life is unpredictable and kind
of scary that's kind of always how it is
you never know exactly what's going to
happen but there are enough brands out
there telling you how we're all in this
together instead here's policy geniuses
top three unpredictably positive things
from April April thousands of dogs and
cats across America have found new homes
everyone's a baker now fresh bread is
the is the best smell ever and people
across the world or acting with kindness
compassion heroism and that's where
policy genius that's what policy genius
is all about policy Gina's compares
quotes
from the top life insurance companies in
one place it just takes a few minutes to
compare quote from the top insurers to
find your best price this doesn't just
save a lot of legwork you could also
save fifteen hundred dollars or more a
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance quotes so if you're one
of the many people looking to buy life
insurance right now but you're not sure
where to start
head to policy genius.com policy genius
will find you the best rate handle the
price the process completely you can
stop worrying about life insurance and
get back to you know living your life
baking your own bread whatever it is
policy genius.com
alright so here's the mayor of LA here's
what he his his tweet with his order
pertaining to the beaches it says LA
Beach is reopened today for active
recreation only such as swimming surfing
running and walking no gathering is
allowed in activities such as sunbathing
and group sports are not permitted you
must wear a face covering and maintain
six feet of distance from others okay so
you can't bike but you can run you can't
sit but you can walk you can't picnic
but you can surf does any of this make
any sense is there any medical or
scientific justification for Eddy this
of course not let me really look at this
soak this in for a minute because
honestly it's not very often that you're
gonna see sitting listed as a prohibited
activity on a beach that doesn't happen
very often so what is the point of this
telling people they have to wear a mask
at the beach when there's no evidence
that the virus can be transmitted in
that environment and even if it could
it's the beach it's very big that's the
thing about the beach it's very easy to
maintain social distance at the beach I
used to live in a beach town and I can
tell you even at its height even at the
busiest part you know July 4th tourist
season you could still easily go to
there's a lot of people at the beach you
could still easily go to the beach and
not come within six feet of another
person because there's a lot of space so
even if the virus could could be
effectively spread outside at the beach
we
doesn't seem that it can even if it
could none of this would make sense
least of all would it make sense to tell
people they can't sit down and relax
especially if you want people to
maintain social distance the easiest way
at the beach to maintain social distance
is to is to pick a spot set up your your
towel and umbrella and that's your spot
that's the easiest way to stay away from
other people if you're telling them they
have to keep moving it's gonna be a lot
harder so what's the point
I think it's obvious that first of all
these petty tyrants don't want to give
up the power they don't want to give up
the crisis and also they don't want to
send a message of optimism and recovery
and normalcy going into an election with
a Republican incumbent I think it's as
simple as that one other point though
about this this whole thing of you know
social distancing and everything and
this is a really obvious point that
shouldn't need to be made but I'm gonna
make it anyway because apparently it
does and I was think about this
especially cuz I want to here's another
picture I want to show you this is
something that someone posted
approvingly on online and it's a picture
from a German cafe and this is what this
German cafe is doing to enforce social
distancing I've actually seen this
before that so that there there are
other places that are doing this and you
see they have their people their patrons
their customers wearing hats with with
pool noodles attached so that they'll
somehow that's supposed to help them
maintain social business because of
course you know when you're sitting down
at a place and there's hot coffee and
everything and drinks and and food yeah
the best thing you want to do is have
people with pool noodles hanging off of
them right what could possibly go wrong
but not only is something like that
embarrassing and emasculating and absurd
and stupid but it's also totally
pointless this is not necessary we don't
need to think of creative and and
patronizing ways to get people to
maintain social distance we don't need
all these complicated rules at the beach
you can do this you could do that you
got to wear a mask right we don't need
any of that it's pee
people understand the concept of giving
each other space and almost everybody is
more than happy to do it it's not hard
that's all you got to say we don't need
any of the rest of this stuff all you
got to say is hey look just give people
some space okay that's all you got to
say and almost everybody is more than
happy to do that even without the
coronavirus people are more than happy
to do that you don't have to tell people
twice to give each other space at the
beach they want space I mean you know
it's it's not like people are running up
and you know kissing strangers on the
mouth for the most part unless it's
spring break but families at the beach
that's not what they're doing they're
going with their own family they want
their own little space and that's fine
you know I mentioned I was out with my
wife on her Mother's Day we were out
with the family we're at a Havre de
Grace in Maryland which is a small
little town on the bay historic town and
there's a lighthouse and there's you
know like a little boardwalk and stuff
and and we were there it was very busy
you know because it's Mother's Day it
would always be busy but especially now
people don't have anywhere else to go so
there's a lot of people there and but
there was no complicate and nobody was
wearing pool noodles on their head
people weren't wearing masks unless they
were going into a store they weren't
wearing them outside
there was no complicated procedure in
place there were no cops patrolling the
area telling us what to do and yet we
figured out how to just enjoy ourselves
and walk around and have a normal time
without while also giving each other
space not hard to do people can figure
that out that's what most people do
anyway
okay when we're walking by someone on
the boardwalk it's not like there's a
moment of panic and confusion and we
don't know what to do so one of us just
jumps into the water no it's just okay
we could clear some space and we just
keep walking that's it just move over
keep walking that's all you need to do
we don't need any of the rest of this
it's as simple as that okay let's go to
the headlines
what before we go to headlines I want to
tell you about our friends hate your
life you know having nice artwork on the
wall of your home can be a games it's
what it's what makes your house a home I
think it's what differently stormy
that's when when I went from living in
the bachelor pad actually living in a
real house with a family you know one of
the ways you could tell is the there's
not that much beer in the fridge for one
thing but also there's artwork on the
are in the walls and paint your life you
know you can get beautiful artwork
that's also meaningful to you if you're
looking for a way to feel connected to
loved ones when you can't be near them
you've got to try paint your life calm
you get a professional hand-painted
portrait created from any photo of yours
at a truly affordable price this is a
user-friendly platform it lets you order
a custom made hand-painted portrait in
less than five minutes it's very easy to
order it's very affordable considering
the quality of work that you're getting
and it's they're also very I did this
myself we're very happy with the
painting we got we have it hanging in
our living room and they're very
responsive throughout the entire process
the artist and it's a real artist okay
it's this is not a Photoshop thing the
artist who's making your painting will
communicate with you and if you want to
change something if you want to go back
and forth you can do that very simple
very responsive at paint your life calm
there's no risk if you don't love the
final painting your money is refunded
guaranteed and right now is a limited
time offer get 20% off your painting
that's right 20% off and free shipping
to get the special offer text the word
matte to 64,000 that's matte to 64,000
text matte to 64,000 paint your life
celebrate the met the moments that
matter most okay the new jobless report
is out this is tradition now of course
the sad tradition now every Thursday
every Thursday at 8:30 in the morning is
when the jobless numbers come out and I
know that now it's sad that I know it
but I do
three million additional unemployed
people last week that brings the
official number to 35 million a little
more than 35 million thirty-five million
okay now think about this for a minute I
think about what the number means
because let's look at this
optimistically as optimistically as we
can let's say and I'm pulling this
number out of thin air but let's say
very optimistically
in a dream fantasy scenario 80% of the
people who lost their job since this all
began or hi are hired back in the next
few months let's say that we can recover
80% of those losses
that's about as optimistic as we could
possibly be I think and and even that
isn't gonna happen but no rational
person thinks that ninety or a hundred
percent of people are gonna be hired
back my point though is that even if it
was 80 percent who were hired back that
would still leave seven or eight million
unemployed people and under normal
circumstances if we had shed eight
million jobs in two months that would be
seen as a crisis as an economic crisis
and now though it's like the dream it's
the hope it's the best-case scenario now
my point isn't to panic anyone or to
make us feel hopeless especially if you
don't have a job right now but I think
we need to be realistic about what we're
heading into number two a little bit of
positivity here let's get away from the
doom and gloom for a moment with the
lock downs and everything you know one
of the good things is that nature is
healing itself nature is returning to
its old glory reclaiming its territory
as the era of human civilization draws
to a close mercifully so here's a great
example this is footage out of
California yesterday watch this it's
very beautiful
the goats have returned the wild goats
have returned as the prophecy foretold
beautiful actually I have no idea what's
happening that video no clue but I saw
it and it was interesting so there it is
number three as if we didn't have enough
on our plate we are now told that nASA
has launched a mission called dart
that's the double asteroid redirection
test mission and the idea is to slam
into an asteroid on purpose
intentionally creating a meteor shower
that's what they're gonna do and this
would be the first human-caused meteor
shower in history what I mean what could
possibly be the drawback they're right
they're telling us it will be harmless
that's what they're saying
but I mean it seems like there are a lot
of variables here a lot of unknowns
the idea is to test their ability to
redirect an asteroid in case one ever
really does threaten earth but but you
know my thing is though first of all can
we stop and have a conversation about
whether we'd actually want to redirect
an asteroid if it was gonna slam into
earth and kill us all I'm just saying
there are two sides of that argument and
I think we should have a discussion
about it that's it second I was at the
lake with my kids the other day and I
threw I threw a rock to skip it across
the the lake and I almost hit a baby
goose in the face by accident I didn't
the goose was okay but I almost did my
point here in this parable is that
disaster almost struck when I threw a
rock into a lake but I was standing
right in front of now we're gonna launch
a missile at an asteroid millions of
miles away that's traveling hundreds of
thousands of miles an hour intending to
redirect it while planet earth stands
precariously in its path I just I don't
know makes me a little uncomfortable
for and tonight watch out for this CNN
is hosting a town hall on the corona
virus and there's going to be an expert
panel here is the expert panel take a
look you see so we've got a couple of
former bureaucrats on the panel so
that's great and then yes Greta Thune
Berg Greta Thune Berg the
sixteen year old is on a panel of
coronavirus experts now lots of people
are making fun of CNN for this saying
you know she's not an expert she's just
she's just a kid who thinks that the
we're all gonna drown next week
that doesn't really make her an expert
in anything especially not a virus and
that's true but look at the name of this
event this is what people are missing in
defense of CNN which I would rarely
offer defenses of CNN look at the name
it says coronavirus facts and fears mean
Greta Thune Berg is indeed an expert on
fear she's an expert on feeling fear
she's an expert on spreading it so
actually I think she does belong on the
panel okay number five finally here is a
video that's going viral right now
online it is reportedly footage of a
confrontation between a woman a woman a
mother with with her with a toddler at
at the subway station in New York
competition treat her and police and
reportedly the the the what started all
this is that she wasn't wearing a face
mask correctly and then here's what
happened next
[Music]
[Applause]
right yes because you know if you're
concerned about germs being spread the
most sensible thing to do is to throw
somebody onto the ground on the floor of
a subway station and then dog pile on
top of them that's that's that's gonna
be a good way to stop the spread of
germs isn't it now I mean you could say
we don't have we don't have all the
context here we don't know exactly what
happened that's fine she was she was
arguing with the police she wasn't
submitting you know like a good little
citizen and and fine that's all true too
but we're gonna see more and more of
this and you just you can't expect
people to tolerate being harassed by
police over issues like this and this is
not how the police department should be
used
you know people this is this is not a
woman who's on a you know with her with
her toddler at the subway station this
is not the kind of dangerous criminal
that we want cops to be chasing after
and the other thing is you know I
understand and I've gotten plenty of
heat I've read some of the emails I
think from some of the police officers
that have written to this show and have
said anonymously that they are you know
they don't like having to enforce these
rules they don't support them the last
thing they want to do when they get up
in the morning and they go into their
job they don't want to go down and start
policing people for how they're wearing
their face masks or if they're not
social distancing correctly I thought
that was another the kind of thing
that's not why you got into the police
force in the first place is to have
enforce laws like that
and and I understand that so the cops
are in a tough spot too but the the
we're just following orders
excuse only goes so far and I think
we've reached its limit personally okay
let's go to your daily cancellation I'm
going to be canceling the hero-worship
of nurses I think it's it's time to
cancel this finally I'm not canceling
nurses themselves because I you know I
like nurses I respect what they do they
have an important job but all I'm asking
for is a little bit of perspective and a
little bit of common sense that's all so
look at this tweet from NBC News ten in
New York it's a picture of a bunch of
nurses holding a sign and the caps
reads healthcare heroes this morning
we're honoring a group from the United
Memorial Center they work in the Lipson
Cancer and infusion center in Batavia
Batavia an underground said their
message we stay here for you you stay
home fro for us thank you for keeping us
safe and healthy okay so first thing
again I respect health care workers
I appreciate what they do it's a
necessary job and generally in my own
personal experience either as a patient
or or when my kids have been patients or
another family member I've generally
been impressed with the nurses that I've
dealt with and that's why I said I've
always liked nurses but this thing where
we call every nurse a hero is just silly
and it cheapens the word hero and it's
patronizing these people in the picture
they work at a Cancer Center in upstate
New York that's great I'm glad they do
it it's very important work
I don't think though going into your
Cancer Center in upstate New York is an
act of heroism I just I don't I don't
think it requires immense courage to do
it you know going into the middle of an
epic
going into the middle of the epicenter
of an epidemic specifically to work with
infected people yes that I will call
heroic certainly but just going to do
your job at your local hospital is is
not heroic it's your job and you're paid
to do it
that's not heroism and that's not an
insult either not insulting you I'm just
saying the word hero has should have
meaning and it loses its meaning when we
just apply it to anybody who wears
scrubs and works at a hospital and
that's the other thing too saying it's
their job well what they're telling us
in that in that sign they're saying stay
home and we'll stay here for you yeah
well it's easy for you to say you get
paid to stay there there are 35 million
people who aren't getting paid anymore
and
like two because they'd like to feed
their families feed their kids there are
35 million people who had jobs like you
also had important jobs okay
I mean anyone's job is important at
least to them and their families and
there are many other kinds of jobs out
there that are important to communities
too and a lot of people a lot of those
people don't have jobs anymore and and
so and they would like to so I'm sorry
but it comes across as selfish for
nurses to say oh all you people stay
home for our sake what
what kind of who says that anyway who
says that who just declares that to
millions of people all you stay home
stay home for us here's what I need you
to do for us stay home be unemployed if
you need to go and get in a bread line
and do that but otherwise stay home do
it for me how is that not an insanely
selfish not to mention tone-deaf message
and it doesn't get any less selfish or
less tone-deaf just because nurses are
saying it you know what would be a
selfless and inspiring message here's
what I would like this would inspire me
and this I would think would be self
selfless from a nurse if the nurses were
to say hey you out there go out live
your life go to your job feed your kids
take care of your of your business do
what you need to if you get sick we'll
be here for you
now now that's a nice message that's an
encouraging message not stay home stay
home unemployed while we work of course
I mean that's been the message from the
media too so that's a common message
these days but it doesn't become
suddenly virtuous or valiant because
nurses are saying and and and you know
by the way also there there are a lot of
people who have been who have medical
problems and and symptoms and have been
staying home as they've been instructed
to and and they shouldn't be because
they should be they should be going to
the doctor and they're not I mean think
about how many cancer how many
answers have gone undiagnosed because of
this that's a whole other aspect of the
shutdown now we're gonna go to some
emails but before we do I want to take a
moment to tell you about Daily wires
newest most exclusive membership tear
all access the all-access membership
here is our premier level of membership
all access members get to participate in
all access live our brand-new
interactive programming feature where
one of us daily wire our hosts hangout
with you each night at 8 p.m. Eastern 5
p.m. Pacific
Michael Knowles will be hosting tonight
so get excited for that all access
members also get to join join us for
live exclusive online Q&A s daily wires
new discussion feature which is
available on both the website and the
daily wire app they also get the benefit
of other membership tiers including an
ADD free website experience access to
all of our live broadcasts and show
library access to the shows mail bags
and the full 3 hours of the Ben Shapiro
show all that stuff you get so head over
to daily wired.com slash subscribe to
join daily wires all-access Club with a
new membership or an upgrade and get 10%
off with coupon code Walsh
that's daily wire comm slash subscribe
see you there alright let's go to a few
emails here in and again if you become a
daily wire remember you can always have
access to the mailbag and send emails
that ways from Tim says hey Matt I just
recently became a daily wired member
came for Ben's staying for Matt just
wanted to get your thoughts on Biden
calling out Trump for not wearing a mask
when going out in public I feel that the
president is trying to portray strength
and show that he isn't afraid
considering he gets tested frequently
and masks are better for protecting
others this seems like just another
feeble attempt to blame Trump for
everything since when is it wrong for a
president to show some courage thanks
for all you do yeah I agree with you Tim
I have no problem with the truck with
with Trump not wearing a mask as you
said everyone around him is getting
tested constantly and he's getting
tested constantly as he should be so I
and and if he's you know if he's
standing you know if he's walking around
or something or he's giving a press
conference I don't know how you give a
press conference in a mask anyway and so
I don't have an issue with that and I
kind of agree I think it would send the
wrong message personally to have him
walking around in a mask all the time I
think we
to remember you know a lot of these
politicians that are wearing masks
they're just doing it for show and no I
don't I don't support I don't support
wearing a mask as a fashion statement or
to virtue signal or just doing it for
show I mean all these people on social
media Facebook and Twitter and stuff
with their their profile pictures now
are them and masks let's did you need to
wear a mask well you took a profile
picture no you didn't you just want to
show off that you're wearing a mask and
you're being responsible I as I've said
before when it comes to the mask thing
if if if a store requires a mask for
entry I'll wear the mask
no problem it's their right to require
it I got no issue with that if that's
what they need to do to get going again
and to end to you know to operate and if
that's what we need to do to get the
economy going perfectly fine but know
this idea that you need to just where we
all need to be wearing masks all the
time everywhere is absurd let's see this
is from Sean says dear Matt you've
confessed to it so I'll just ask when
you and Clavin or trespassing on private
property construction sites during your
Bob Villa LARPing sessions when you left
the private property you had no business
being in and you are immediately
confronted by an armed neighbor who
demands you stop and explain what the
hell you were doing in that house what
would your reaction be one stop
apologize profusely explain yourself or
to fight the neighbor to the death for
his gun ask Clavin what his answer is to
please yeah this is or nuts from that
might've been from Jason see there from
Jason or Shawn I lost the name anyway
whoever whoever sent that email what
he's referring to is now I can't speak
for Clavin I don't know what clave ins
stances on this I'm not gonna speak to
that but I you know I I mentioned that
when people are talking about with with
Arbor II and the fact that he was on a
construction site again I don't know why
he was on the site okay maybe he was a
burglar the homeowner says they did
nothing was stolen that to me is
significant but who knows what he was
doing there he could have had sinister
motivations I don't know but
it doesn't have to be sinister I can
imagine a scenario where somebody would
go on a construction site not intending
to steal anything just to kind of check
it out now I have done that myself I'm
not I don't go out and do it every day
I'm not I'm not running you know driving
around looking for construction sites to
trespass on but there have been times in
my life when I have been walking by
something under construction I stopped
to take a look I've done that I thought
it was kind of normal I thought it was
something that guys do sometimes
apparently not from the reaction I've
gotten apparently it's not normal okay
I'll admit that so I have been guilty of
that in the past of trespassing now to
answer your question let's say I stopped
I look at a construction site and as I'm
leaving a guy runs up with a gun to
confront me what would I do
the first answer is I don't know because
I think you can't ignore would do in
that situation until you're in it but I
think there's a very good possibility
that I would run because I don't know
who this guy is I don't know what his
intention is I don't know if he's crazy
and he's about to shoot me for being on
a construction site and yeah I should
have been on it but that doesn't mean
I'm gonna offer myself to be shot okay
so yes I might well run which is what
our burry apparently did originally so
from what we aren't from from from how
we understand the situation now it seems
as though originally confronted he ran
they chased him down parked their car in
the middle of the road to head him off
one guys on the street with a gun
another guys up with a truck bed with a
gun and so it's only in that second
interaction if we can call it that that
are buried decided rather than flee he
was gonna fight I could see myself doing
that too frankly you know the person
confronts you with a gun you don't know
if they're crazy and they're gonna kill
you so you just you just you don't
really want to stick around and find out
so you run you know I think when someone
confronts with a gun running is a pretty
understandable reaction even if you're a
burglar I mean
say that I was on the construction site
burglarizing it let's say I was there
stealing power tools or something and
then somebody runs up with a gun I'd
still run I'm probably not gonna just
stop and say pop you got me do what you
will I deserve it
I'm probably in a run because I don't
want to die and then that second time
when you when you see that scene there's
they're parked in the middle of the
freakin streets with guns yeah you might
think at this point okay these people
really want to kill me and now I got a
now it's a it's a it's a fight to the
death I could see someone making that
calculation I could I mean you say Jason
or Shawn whoever you are that you can't
you can't see that you don't understand
it alright I guess I'll take your word
for that
but to me it doesn't seem that
unreasonable it doesn't seem that
unreasonable to conclude when people are
coming after you with guns that they
might want to kill you I think that's a
logical conclusion I don't know burglar
or not that's my point
rather they're he's a burglar or not
this is from Steve says hello mr. Walsh
I'm not sure if you'll get this or not
but I'll keep it short a 77 year old
barber here in Michigan is being
railroaded by the Michigan State AG and
our governor he chose to go back to work
at the barber shop
he owns because he was broke and had no
other choice they tried to shut him down
in issue citations he won't he will he
won in a court case the judge chose the
state could not file a temporary
restraining order so because they lost
in court they simply chose to pull his
license with no due process maybe if
enough people find out about this we can
help him out I'm a big fan if you can if
you can't talk about it or don't have
time I understand really love your show
thank you for your time
I hadn't heard about this case thanks
for passing it along I'll look into it I
mean that sounds completely outrageous
but it's also doesn't surprise me with
what's happening up there in Michigan so
yeah thanks for passing it along and I
will I'll look into that I think we're
gonna see we're gonna see a lot of them
you look in Wisconsin like I mentioned
they tried the governor tried to extend
a state home order state Supreme Court
shut it down thank God
said he's not allowed to do it well you
know I is the is the are these petty
tyrants gonna give up that easy and say
okay fine
now they're gonna find other ways around
it to control people and so I think
we're gonna see a lot more of this
thanks for passing that along we'll
leave it there for today thanks for
watching everybody
god speed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 hey everybody its Andrew
Clavin host of the Andrew Clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the American Republic is
collapsing the end of days is
approaching and the moon has turned to
blood but on the Andrew Clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the Andrew Clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]